you're starting your business you're  going to need to promote in order to  promote there are three things that are  required number one is who you're trying  to reach which is your avatar number two  is what media which is the actual medium  are you gonna use video or you're gonna  use text are you gonna use long form you  have to pick the one that you're best at  third is you gotta pick the platform  where these avatars are and this medium  is and so once you pick that platform  then you're going to figure out the  activity which is what activities do i  need to do in order to reach them  there's only two you can reach out to  them 101 or you can broadcast through  posts etc and you're going to do as much  of both of those two things as you can  because those are the only two things  that will get your new customers